If Godzilla comes to mind when asked who you
think is at the top of the reptilian food
chain - think again.
You may be very - VERY mistaken.
SCP-682, also known as the Hard to Destroy
Reptile, is one of the most deadly and infamous
creatures on the SCP Foundation’s roster.
But what makes this beast so feared?
First, as the name suggests, it’s pretty
much impossible to kill.
Multiple cross-tests with other SCPs - from
SCP-173 to SCP-096 - have heavily injured
the creature, but it has a remarkable ability
to adapt to and overcome seemingly any form
of attack leveraged against it.
It often even goes a step further, and weaponizes
what was used against it by taking on it’s
opponents anomalous ability itself!
Second, it’s both highly intelligent and
incredibly malicious.
It claims to find all life disgusting, and
if it had its way, it would happily slaughter
any and every living thing.
It’s kept in a tank of highly potent acid
to prevent its escape, and it’s believed
to be a potential offspring of the infamous
Scarlet King.